I didn't think I'm really gonna play
that Wow
get out the pumpkin spice everything
folks because the leaves are changing
soon and that means it's horror movie
season but which horror film will rule
the fall let's talk about it right now
on the ketchup it's actually been a
pretty great year for horror movies
already because of certified fresh hits
like midsummer crawl and us which pulled
in two hundred and fifty five million
dollars at the box office
throw in strong showings from our little
friends Chucky and Annabelle emphasis on
the little and I think it's safe to say
that horror as a genre continues to be
on the rise nice doll
coming up very soon on August 21st is
ready or not
starring Samara weaving and Adam Brody
and it's co-written by Ryan Murphy the
movies about rich people playing a
killer game of hide and seek you know
like getting lost in their massive
mansions and stuff and as if committing
to one person for the rest of your life
isn't scary enough this movie features a
bride that discovers that her in-laws
are out to kill her so yeah maybe don't
go see this one before you tie the knot
I know you're in here
and we're just getting started friends
because it's coming you know it chapter
two is coming the highly anticipated
sequel to 2017 certified fresh'
moneymaker it will hit theaters on
September 6 and Bill skarsgård is back
as the creepy clown who eerily sounds
like Winnie the Pooh pee but the kids
from the first one of age 26 years and
now look a lot like James McAvoy Jessica
Chastain and Bill Hader just to name a
few
and that's why fans like this one on
Twitter will be heading to the cinema
for it chapter 2 by any means necessary
how does he do that anyway while we're
talking about sequels to Stephen King
based horror royalty we got to mention
dr. sleep the follow-up to 1980
certified fresh' The Shining perhaps
you've heard of it this one opens
November 8th and stars Ewan McGregor as
a grown up Danny
and even though Stephen King himself has
said he didn't much care for Stanley
Kubrick's classic take on his book fans
will be relieved to know that this movie
very much lives in the universe Stan Lee
created I was called it the shining
coming on October 18th is the black and
white horror film with the most
terrifying title the lighthouse the
films about two lighthouse keepers on a
remote
Aylin in the 1890s this one stars Robert
Pattinson and Willem Dafoe and was
directed by Robert Eggers who is known
for 2016 certified fresh' to which and
if you're wondering exactly how scary
this movie will be like me
consider that Dafoe described the film
to variety as quote a little like
Hitchcock with a certain amount of humor
and let's be honest just having the
presence of Willem Dafoe and the smell
definitely ups the creepy factors a few
notches if you know what I mean
some other upcoming horror films worth
noting include next month's haunt about
an extra scary haunted house on
Halloween that was produced by horror
vet Eli Roth and we're in and directed
by scott beck and ryan woods who by the
way are the same guys who wrote 2018
certified fresh' a quiet place but this
time they'll actually get to write work
there's also the lodge with Alicia
Silverstone and Riley Keough slated for
November and Black Christmas starring
Cary Elwes and Imogen Poots and Brahms a
boy tune with Katie Holmes both coming
in December
welcome back Katie I never stopped
thinking about you so as you guys can
see there's a lot of screens coming our
way and it's time to kick it over to you
now
which horror film are you most excited
for this fall do you prefer horror in
the theatres or streaming at home and
seriously penny wise sounds like Winnie
the Pooh am i right let us know all your
feelings in the comments section and
tell us what other stories you'd like to
see us cover and for all the latest
horror movie news head on over to Ryan
Tomatoes calm we got you covered and by
the way thanks for watching the new
Artie show the ketchup as always I'm s
Perez and I'll see you guys next time
you
[Music]